this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from thorough history and on
this week's episode he's taking a look
at the utterly bombastic guns from the
2016 doom and its sequel doom eternal i
think i'm getting the message of doing
maternal here the redesigned weapons are
at least some of them have this mythical
fantasy legend style over designing
going on that makes them look more metal
it's like the gun equivalent of a conan
sword if you're a fan of jonathan then
definitely make sure to check out the
series playlist in the description of
this video and down there you'll also
find more videos from other experts all
the way from swords to cats and of
course if there are any other games guns
and mechanics you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below right let's check
out the weapons of doom
all right the pistol is of course a
starting weapon in just about every fps
ever ever made i can't help but cast my
mind back to the original doom games and
um what was sort of a beretta 92
thing but it was kind of modeling a real
panga a modern sort of handgun felt more
grounded the reboot doom is
inherently less grounded so i guess the
the halo esque space pistol sort of
works i don't really remember it very
well i think it's just a function of
pistols being rubbish in uh fbs games
this is an energy weapon from its
depiction its sound effect however it
does eject what looked to be not much
different than brass rimmed metallic
cartridge cases with a little blue glow
around the case head i think that's been
done for as i often say visual interest
purposes because i'm not really sure how
why or how an energy weapon would need
cases so if i had a critique of this i'd
say why does it have cartridge cases the
sites are not really relevant in this in
this game but they are modelled and they
look like sort of vaguely spacey night
sights with glowing inserts in them and
i think overall the thing kind of looks
a bit it's a little bit nerf gun maybe
it is a science fiction gun so can't be
too harsh
right next up we've got the single
barreled shotgun or the ordinary shotgun
the trigger is really weird i don't know
if they're going for maybe an
electronically or electrically fired gun
that would be one reason why the trigger
might be so slim and yet kind of
wrapping around the finger i think
that's purely an aesthetic choice i
think butt stock area something that
often gets lost in translation with
science fiction weapons is
or are ergonomics in the sense of it's
it's
form over function quite quite
frequently and what often happens is the
butt stock is sort of deprecated and
here we see it's a very small butt plate
quite thick if that is indeed meant to
be a soft butt plate made of rubber or
something but quite small surface area
for how big and hefty the gun is it's
also not directly in line with the
sights on top of the gun which is a
problem for perceived recoil
in terms of the muzzle rise that would
result from that ideally you want a
straight line through from the muzzle
through the sights to your shoulder in
terms of recoil as long as the gun is in
a straight line you'll find
we are on to a version of the gun that i
have not used some similar design cues
it weirdly looks less advanced at first
glance and this is first glance to me
still has a pump grip and that's clearly
key to the gameplay still has a tiny
butt plate and the line of recoil is is
still low but basically everything else
is different so we have a more
conventional looking trigger there
different lines it's like a
model of car 10 years apart but it does
basically the same but the styling is is
different and maybe it has some a few
extra
features
that's a useful analogy but to me it
actually looks less advanced but that's
purely an aesthetic thing
insta pause there because this is very
different we actually have a revolver
shotgun here but he's also pump action
it's like a gatling shotgun that also
has a pump grip pretty unusual i think
somehow the back half is feeding shotgun
shells either into a single barrel and
then you're pumping them in and out or
it's somehow feeding one barrel after
the other and then systems like a
redundant revolver feed mechanism
however this standard pump action module
as i'll call it i'm not sure what the
game calls it is not the whole story
because we have this ominous green
cylinder perched on the back of the gun
and when when we see the player alt fire
we actually get a sort of long recoil
effect with a whole upper barrel to punt
a grenade so it's like an over and under
shotgun grenade launcher where the
grenade launches self-loading and is on
top of the gun and the pump action
shotgun is underneath and his pump
action slightly melting my mind but it's
the opposite way around to normal guns
gives you quite a lot of variety from
what used to be a bog standard pump
action shotgun that was like the second
worst weapon in the game this is golem
or option to stay with it
assault rifle back in my day
there was no assault rifle and
basically the chain gun was your rapid
bullet firing gun later games including
this went with a more conventional
assault rifle very hard to judge scale
from this view but having checked
this is actually 50 caliber so
presumably meant to be our present day
50 browning machine gun round kind of
looks right for that they may not have
they won't have slavishly followed the
exact dimensions of the case or the
projectile i wouldn't have thought but
we do have here i'm pretty certain the
link and a different link system so it's
not the old-school more old-school
version used by the soviets with its
non-disintegrating where you reuse the
belt push new rounds in and it's not the
more western approach of disintegrating
link that we see this in games where
they spew out the side along with the
cases this appears to be a form of i
guess 50 bmg where the link is part of
the case which is weird i could be wrong
but that's what it looks like weird and
a really bad idea because you are
weakening the case and with something as
powerful as 50 bmg the pressures are
very high and if you weaken the case
that's where it's going to it's going to
break you also have the feed problem how
do you get the round
out of that link if the link is built
into the case or do you somehow form a
chamber around the round and fire it in
situ in the feed way that doesn't make
any sense
the actual alt-fire for this is
intriguingly enough not entirely made up
although this gives you a a miniature
pop-up mlrs multiple launch rocket
system which is definitely not available
there is something uh from raytheon
called the pike now this is still
developmental the concept was for a step
up from the underbarrel grenade launcher
so the classic 40 millimeter launcher
that we know but the pike would be the
same idea so an under barrel sort of
module effectively but it's a mini
missile and you have um your optical
sight is
interfaces with that and it fuses it
appropriately so it would
this is true for some grenade launchers
too so the round could go through a door
before it detonates or over cover before
it detonates but it's guided it would be
guided as well so think of a 40
millimeter launcher that bloops out of
your gun but then tracks the target
you've identified and kills it which is
what we see in doom i am a little
surprised maybe i've not played enough
game games lately but um that ain't one
of our one of these near future games
that were very popular in the last five
years or so from memory did not do that
and it's actually something that's been
worked on i remember holding a resin
replica of the missile at a defense show
once being disappointed that it wasn't
more of a real thing
right now this is another total redesign
but keeping the concept the same we've
got now twin packs of mini missiles one
on each side still got iron sights
they're very different but they're not
any more advanced again i get the idea
that this is
meant to be from a different company so
it's doing all the same stuff that the
the customer expects
of a death dealing weapon but in an
aesthetically and slightly functionally
different way which is a if that's the
case i mean they probably don't even
spell this out in the game but it's a
good way to keep functionality game to
game but to change things up
one major change here that's not what's
not a major change it's a visual change
is that we have a some sort of i guess
it's a recoil system where the whole
front of the gun is recoiling as the gun
fires there aren't many guns that do
that the only thing that comes to mind
would be the
an-94 where it's like a gun recoiling
inside a gun but it does that in order
to be able to fire two rounds at a rate
of 2 000 plus rounds per minute it
doesn't do it for
well it does do it for recoil reasons
but only because the firing two shots at
the same time would create too much
recoil that makes sense this doesn't do
that this has a steady rate of fire but
still has a
recoiling barrel effectively
aha so the the most fun weapon in any
doom game the super shotgun still called
a super shotgun pleasingly but it's
still relatively conventional so i've
grabbed a couple from the collection
because with sci-fi games we are a
little
usually a little lacking because we're
not there yet so this is one
option for a sauna shotgun
wisely this person whoever they may have
been has kept the buttstock intact
because that makes it far more capable
you can actually
aim it properly even if you're not
aiming it you can use the the stock to
keep proper grip on the thing keep
control of it interestingly you can see
here not the same decoration of course
but there's a strong trend in shotgun
design to decorate the breech with some
sometimes some very nice deep engraving
quite different to the doom one but you
can definitely see the lineage there's
very little difference other than the
shape of where the breech is is stocked
you've been they've even got a couple of
sort of pin things there that look like
they they attach to the to the wood it's
still got the lever on the top exactly
like this so push the lever to the side
open it up that click is it cocking but
i've also grabbed this one because it's
closer in
configuration or at least at the back
end so you can see here where the wood
has been cut away to the point where
they've revealed the bolt that holds the
buttstock onto the gun it's typically a
big bolt
up through the back they have though
done quite a good job of finishing off
the wood and they've kept because this
would have been what's called a semi
pistol grip here so in other words this
would be intact and then there'd be a
butt stock springing off the back like
this that means you can remove all that
wood and get a true pistol grip albeit
is an awkward shape because it was
designed for holding with a butt stock
not for
mad maxing it even shorter barrels
making it really a sort of giant pistol
so this is
if someone says sword off shotgun or
sword off shotgun it's probably this
type that you're going to think of these
things with any any kind of
like significantly damaging
or lethal ammunition like buckshot or
slug the recoil is significant but they
can be fired from one hand i have done
it
the super shotgun i have not played it's
gone very
fantasy i think it's fair to say well
more than sci-fi it has um well almost a
gears of war vibe with the twin blades
under the on the fore end there much
bulkier still has the the extra raised
rib on the top of the top of the breech
which is a feature of the original gun
as well very convoluted design we've got
some very deeply etched i guess it would
be if it was real decoration much more
angular looking the the the wood is sort
of merged into the design in a way that
the original isn't and a real sort of
shotgun wouldn't be uh we do have we do
have sort of runes and symbols down the
side so i'm guessing this is a in
context this is a legendary ancient
weapon of some sort that we come across
like the original super shotgun or
something
okay i'd i'd forgotten the the um
gameplay that i'd seen from this from
when it launched that the blades under
the barrel are not in fact some sort of
gears-esque bayonets they are in fact
your hook shots so that's a very
interesting way to make a gun that's
been done to death something special and
different yeah i can't comment on the
use of grappling under barrel grapple
grab no guns
they're not really a thing grapple guns
are though they have been made and
they've been made to work but i don't
think anyone's using them in the way
that we see in the movies and this is
they're certainly not using them to
skewer things with and pull themselves
into them in the way that we see here
but it is extremely cool and leverages
the devastating double barrel effect of
the super shotgun in a very creative way
a fair bit of variety out of this rocket
launcher is it a rocket launcher i mean
it sort of does launch rockets um with a
sort of visible
rockety behavior where there's some sort
of smoke trail almost behaves like a lot
of games this thing almost behaves more
like a grenade launcher in that it has
visible recoil and the speed of the
projectile is more like it's being
lobbed through the air than shooting
through the air at speed now of course
that is a gameplay thing because it
gives the in multiplayer gives the
ability to dodge and in single it lets
you it means you have to lead shots and
things so yeah we covered that before in
this series we also get multiple
little bursts of mini rockets we get a
very obvious arcing trajectory grenade
that explodes we've got a lock-on
feature as well with an attachment there
it kind of does everything that an
explosive weapon needs to do what is
interesting from a functional standpoint
is this sort of almost tank-esque
auto-loader device that seems to be
present in the back of the gun where
it's rotating to select around and
feeding it into the breach kind of a
cool idea that implies there's something
else going on under the hood even if it
doesn't necessarily make practical sense
i think i'm getting the message of doing
maternal here the redesigned weapons are
at least some of them have this mythical
fantasy legend style over designing
going on that makes them look more metal
and this is the most metal weapon i've
seen so far it has actual skulls on it
the eyes are glowing uh this is like if
alchemy gothic made a
rocket launcher it's got chains on it
runes lots of angles pointy bits that
would hurt if you held it but it's i
like it because it's um it's like the
gun equivalent of a conan sword
completely impractical ludicrously heavy
does nothing to improve function in fact
and probably make it worse but it's you
know this is a legendary hero version of
the doom guy so why wouldn't it be like
this
okay so the the big bit of chain at the
top of the gun is not purely for
decoration that is somehow part of the
mechanism so as the rear part of the
weapon reciprocates for loading kind of
the chain kind of relaxes and tenses and
i can't imagine how that would actually
work well it wouldn't work but really
does look cool
okay now this this is a good bit of
design i think because it screams energy
weapon the way the the lines kind of
flow into each other the obligatory
knuckle bow trigger guard just the
general general design aesthetic of it
to me says it's an energy weapon the
pipes that run around the side this is
like a hint of a power pack there and
the sort of emitters at the front that
vaguely resemble
the front end of the original doom
plasma rifle so that at least when
you're holding the thing it's
reminiscent of the original games so not
not a hugely practical design but almost
stereotypical sci-fi energy weapon but
it's an original design it's not
something i've seen before it has the
vibe of a
maybe an anime gun
there's a good bit of bonus gameplay
with this in that typically your energy
weapons like this will overheat and
that's a bad thing because you can't
shoot it for a period of time till it
cools down doom has turned it into a
benefit by giving you a close range
blast effect when the thing vents its
built up heat so it does give you a
slight still a slight disadvantage and
you can't resume shooting
normal energy bolts right you know right
away but you do get a if you if you time
it right and this is almost like a
rhythm game isn't it the way if you play
it properly you can exploit that
needless to say not something that real
guns do
no this is this is cool the do maternal
plasma rifle is a real throwback so if
there was a slightest hint of the front
end of the original gun in the 2016 game
and i'm probably probably seeing things
there this is a
an homage to the original plasma rifle
coloration design on on the front end
certainly and then they've gone a bit
more to town
on the back to make it a bit different
i like i like the throwback the the re
reimagining of the original weapon let's
have a look at it functioning
all right so we have a similar heat up
mechanic here but instead of a dedicated
indicator all the glowy bits on the gun
turn purple and that's your visual
indicator as to when your gun's
overheating and doing doing its thing
there's a lot going on here in terms of
mechanics but it's obviously not
mechanical stuff moving back and forth
we've got the sort of i guess like an
energy reactor in the middle of the gun
that's spinning that implies that energy
is being generated it's a really really
nice design not normally a fan of brown
but
[Music]
it works as a callback
right this is a confusing beast so it is
um clearly a sort of sci-fi
metal crossbow thing with sort of
industrial steel cable as the um string
uh but it looks almost like a coil gun
in that there's a row of something in in
place of a of a barrel or a knocking
support for the for what would be a bolt
but i don't know it i can't quite tell
if it's hyper accelerating a bolt or
coral or if it's actually an energy
weapon but then if it is why are there
steel cables there and why is it
designed like a giant crossbow and
there's a skull on top of it because of
course there is
this is not a chain gun i've seen before
so um this is do maternal i mean the
term chain gun is kind of was kind of
wrong from the outset uh because it's
that just means a machine gun driven by
a chain and maybe the original mini gun
like chain gun was driven by a chain
don't know this is something rather
different from what i remember from 2016
we've got cartridges belts of cartridges
or shoots of cartridges but they are
energy cartridges they're glowing and
they are blue so it's what it would
imply that this is actually a plasma
another form of plasma gun but what is
undeniably awesome is
there's an alternate fire where the
multiple rotating barrels splay out and
all
fire at once
okay so it's actually generating some
sort of energy shield we have
gun shields in this collection from the
16th century that are around steel
shield or composite with steel shield
with a match lock gun sticking through
the middle you can reload from behind i
don't have access to any in here very
very early
idea of this sort of concept and you'll
have seen attempts to put shields on on
guns more typically what you'll see is
something like a swat team with a
ballistic shield and they've got a gun
that they're using around the shield the
shields and guns are a thing and this is
obviously just a very extrapolated
sci-fi version of it in fact the shield
can be left behind to use as cover is
interesting
[Applause]
[Music]
would you like me to disable the safety
protocols
[Applause]
[Music]
jesus
interesting so we've got bfg 10 000
turned up to 11 but it's 10 instead
like an orbital weapon i mean i guess
the housing kind of magnifies the power
like a death star but then we've got the
ability to turn it into a gameplay
weapon effectively proper proper
gameplay weapon by sort of ripping out
the gun bit and it's effectively just
the bfg 9000 with a new look i imagine
it's going to function much the same way
but i i kind of wish i'd played this
first just because that was a very cool
moment i love the impatient tapping on
the trigger
exactly the same effect that we are used
to seeing with
big old ball of green energy and then
when it hits radiating beams that affect
that has essentially create a it's an
airy effect isn't it can't help you with
reality on this one at all i'm afraid
not the gun and not the idea that
somehow taking the breach of a heavy
weapon off means you can use it as a
light weapon not how weapons work not
yet anyway
thanks guys those were the guns of doom
and doom eternal i've really got to
catch up now that i've seen some
gameplay from the sequel do come and
visit us we've got events going on this
summer admittedly they are elizabethan
themed rather than uh sci-fi murder
themed but um
we very much welcome you to visit or
check out our website our various social
media channels indeed our own youtube
channel where you can hear more of me
wittering on with some guns thanks very
much
[Music]
[Music]
you